getting the call tonight for the
cardinals his record is owen two he had
55 pitches in his previous start we saw
him last night
and on the first pitch a ground ball
there is goldschmidt he'll step on the
bag and we are underway here in st louis
coda hudson he relies on
a sharp infield defense first pitch
swinging two pitch two outs
huh
is it that easy
and the next to him
fly ball out to left over is o'neill and
a one two three inning for dakota hudson
and that could be a good sign here in
game two
for bounce back right-hander anthony
diesel funny
well he looked at hit a little bull his
first couple of starts out there until
the pirates ambushed him last time out
scalfani ahead no balls and two strikes
on the ground right at mustaches
one down has what he wants now the
payoff
in the air to left winker to else
the pitch to carpenter is lined to right
galvez with a leaping catch in shallow
right field
and the inning is over what a play by
freddie galvez cardinals go quietly in
the first as the reds did
here's the 02 pitch and it's a swing and
a miss and a strikeout
guy how do you pitch to that guy
swinging a miss and the tag applied by
molina
payoff again
swing and a miss
runners at first and second
swaying in a miss he struck him out
winker is saying that he got it
i mean it's something you have to hear
and
i don't think he heard it i can't tell
whether he tipped it or not but i do
know that the initial call was strike
three
that could be a big play in this game
runners on the move on the ground
carpenter's play will be to first
easy jesse
very awkward going across there and you
can see the grimace
and he limped around a little bit and
slowly went out the left field he's
still in the game
we're scoreless here in the bottom of
the third one out
went high again and blew him away big
out because you can't rest on your
laurels with matt carpenter coming to
the plate there they go it's taken
inside ball four and carpenter draws a
bases loaded walk in it's one to nothing
cardinals interesting fred bird ironing
um he brought his laundry and he's
ironing
now i never ever thought i'd see that
and apparently he's quarantined up there
so he actually that's where he has to do
his irony he's hanging out doing a
little ironing
i'm just i'm fixated by it
maybe
maybe folks could give him not that he
needs any more ideas does he
here's a strikeout of uh suarez that's
priceless so they're loaded up again
cardinals have received five walks thus
far in the ball game three in this
setting and it brings in brad miller
miller high chopper towards mustaches
flips the second they'll get that man
and throw back to third everybody's safe
there but a run does score and that
makes it a two nothing saint louis lead
and the reds have them loaded the tying
run in scoring position see how this one
works out because matt davidson is a the
guy that they literally will only send
up against left-handed pitching
took a hack davidson a drive to left
grand salami
way back there matt davidson
changes the game around in one swing
so the cardinals roll the dice with the
lefty against davidson and pay the price
4-2 reds
barnard off with the mask has room one
out
goldschmidt drives one deep to center
field
jankowski
on the track next day or the next day
and the next day you show up at the park
and say you know what i want to stay
here yeah so what do i have to do to get
better what do i have to do to to keep
performing so i can
keep this job
strikeout for woodford and that's nine
strikeouts of the reds tonight
if he hits it at all
down goes carpenter
strike three call
near garrett back to back punch outs
it's usually a little miscommunication
between catcher and pitcher
swaying and a miss good start for reisel
here in the ninth hitters can hit 98 if
you're throwing it down the middle first
pitch swinging is molina going towards
the line castillanos makes a nice play
got a good jump on that ball 1-1 pitch
on the ground back to rycell over tovato
and that'll do it so iglesias does
indeed get back on that horse
and the reds even up this four game set
at a game apiece